un tonnerre d'applaudissements pour
notre ami al vous savez quelle
différence il ya entre adolf hitler et
al capone
hitler est mort cappone vie comme un roi
en floride les dément pas qu'un peu j'ai
des raisons croire qu'ils nous roule
dans la farine
qu'est-ce qui se passe selon nos
informations votre client pourrait avoir
caché au fisc une très grosse somme
d'argent
c'est bon tu peux arrêter ton cinoche
fait venir des sbires qui se baladent
partout
[Musique]
un gars comme toi
sap erp à 10 millions de dollars
je peux peut-être amené à me parler de
faire un carnage je vous préviens
on s'était fait la promesse qu'un beau
jour on serait puissant
[Musique]
ce qui définit vraiment un homme
c'est comment il traite sa famille